[Music]
[Music]
yes we did cause we back at it again
fire
back at it again
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby here with Chet Hanks I said
it
and and the man the living legend yeah
well I'm happy with his arms of course
you're sizing them up but the kid's in
shape he's tight
I take in I don't take in a man's arms
chest and shoulders I take in his
[ __ ] lower body because that's what
it really comes down to is he working
with an ass working with thighs yes I
don't see size I just see heart
dude I'm sorry you're not superficial
bro not he could be a hundred pounds I
could give a flying wow crap it'd be
funny if Chad just did this whole
podcast without the mic in front of him
I know he's just on his phone though I
had to do my little story post no there
was someone I forget who this famous uh
music someone came a podcast or
something the whole time I was like a
breakfast club or something like they're
just on their phone like hey my friend
do you mind my friend was on a date with
Britney Spears and apparently she was on
her phone literally the whole time yeah
he's like the [ __ ] is going on here now
this is probably years ago right it was
years ago yeah yeah
have been a flip phone it might have
been it would have been worse because
then she'd really have to be taking her
time typing everything oh those took a
hot second I had no pictures or nothing
were you nice with it I could do it in
my pocket without even having to look at
this game did you have a pager no no
wait how old that was a little bit I
just barely missed that how old are you
32. okay yeah Pedro's kind of out of you
I was like I was like 11 years old when
like Pages yeah you don't want to be the
kid who didn't need one with a page I
mean I figured maybe you'd have a pager
I don't know even if you're 11. I just
missed it yeah like my older cousins had
pagers they never just like a few years
they were exhausting because my dad you
know he's the one who got me that pager
is red I remember some girl stole it and
she showed up in class wearing it I
didn't say [ __ ] what what uh I got
punked but my dad knew if he typed like
his number the 9-1-1 I was like oh [ __ ]
here we go seriously I'd call him like
what are you doing I'm like I don't know
is there an emergency like no so make
sure you call me like I'm not a pay
phone dad or pay phones do you know what
I think about Chet right now collect
calls
um but I'm used to send texts using
pigeons yeah I did I did like like in
that scene in Training Day at the
rooftop yes yeah are we send dick pics
just draw out his dick and send it well
I would send I would draw I'm Papyrus
with a feather pen and ink squid and
then I would attach it to the pigeon and
I would go whip away
clip away enjoy this dick picking you're
free enjoy the stick pick in six months
you're free yes
um you know what I like about you dude I
say this out loud
you've been you grew up in Hollywood you
grew up with all the trappings and
you're not Hollywood you did a good job
of resisting the insanity and and the
the
um the Embrace that causes you to be out
of touch with reality and I feel like
you had this deep sense of kind of
understanding the dangers they're in
maybe it's because your parents are good
people and they knew how to read you'd
have to talk to the parents right shout
out to your mom well but it's also it's
also there's a limit to what parents can
do the kids got to understand where he
fits in the universe where he fits in
the world a lot of his parenting though
for sure don't don't disagree with me
but uh no but I'm kidding but yes it is
but it's also as an individual you go
hold on I see the dangers over here I'm
gonna move over here maybe music saved
you was it was it designed like this
like you didn't want to be in that like
you saw what your dad has to deal with
the credit definitely goes to my parents
for how they raise me just because
they're not Hollywood you know they they
want to be like as low-key as possible
you know they they don't like doing a
any of that [ __ ] you know they're very
very just under the radar but also you
know like there were kids
that I knew growing up that would like
the type of kids that would be like do
you know who I am and that [ __ ] to me
was just I never related but it's not
about I was never that type of dude
yeah I just even at a young age I
thought that was just [ __ ] pathetic
you know but I know a lot of kids I'm
not talking about the I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about something
different I'm talking about like a lot
of kids it's not that they're saying you
know who I am they just can't help but
get
um
it it has a subtle corruption to it
self-sabotage no it's like a
self-importance thing thinking the whole
world is is this when there's an entire
world out there with people that have
that don't live the way you do it all
and I think you always seem to have kept
that in the in the Forefront or the back
here that's right your parents gave you
perspective definitely and also I was
aware like growing up that I was like
kind of being raised in a bubble and I I
really wanted to go out of my way to
experience you know real life because
you were born raised in Malibu is that
right Civic policies yeah so what did
you do to do that well I mean that was
kind of like a double-edged sword too
because you know I kind of like you know
made a lot of mistakes obviously but
that's really kind of like
subconsciously always just kind of
seeking to break through my bubble and
experience real [ __ ] because it did as I
started to get older you know like into
my teenage years I realized that I kind
of like was developing a insecurity
which is that I knew that I grew up
sheltered and that I grew up in this
bubble and that made me feel unprepared
to deal with you know the real world
because even at a young age like I had a
cousin right who was younger than me you
know when you're growing up you know
when you're you know 13 14 a year is
like a big deal yeah so my cousin was
like a year younger than me but he was
like way more worldly and experienced
and had been exposed to things that I
hadn't been exposed to because I was
going to private school and he was going
to you know Venice High you know what
I'm saying so yeah like that like I
didn't like that I didn't like feeling
that that I was like this like sheltered
you know like person so I really as I
got older it kind of like it flipped a
switch to where I wanted to like go out
of my way to experience as much as
possible
um and you know it it kind of like led
me down the wrong path but at the same
time like I got the experience that I
was looking for yeah you're almost like
uh when it comes to your family you're
what's like the Dark Horse like you're
gonna do go your own route you know what
I'm saying yeah you're a bit of an
outlaw in that sense it could be easy to
go the other route that most of us think
you'd go down yeah that's a cool way to
put it yeah yeah when it comes to Hank's
family you're the outlaw you know yeah I
mean yeah I just uh
yeah man it's not a bad thing no I was
just just you know I just
it's just I'm just being myself at the
end of the day you know but at a certain
point when I was younger it's like I I
really wasn't being true to myself
because it's almost like because I
because like I said I was operating from
insecurity so I was really like over
compensating to like do bad [ __ ] yeah
you know what I'm saying just so I could
feel like I could catch up because I
felt behind in just my level of
experience that's what a man that's like
that all men boys
feel that like the biggest fear is that
we're [ __ ] so yeah we're not tough or
that we can't handle the slings and
arrows you know what I mean so it's like
um I like using Shakespearean
terminology yeah yeah yeah
I don't know where's my camera is
um but yeah but um with you so because
I'm sure the the idea of being an actor
had to go down
you know it would have to be in a route
you were thinking about because
obviously your brother does it who's
amazing actor so good you're right off
to your dad I mean it's arguably great
dad's a good actor okay Small Time Crazy
talk yeah as well done yeah and my mom
too yeah it's like being Michael
Jordan's son
your mom's no slouch no yeah but it's
also if you're Michael Jordan's son you
get in basketball hey dude heavy lies
the crown like there's some expectations
yeah so for you if and for your brother
too shout out to him like there's
expectations he's a damn good actor like
it may be your dad opened doors for him
but that dude has all the talent right
so for you if you're gonna go down that
road you better be pretty damn good yeah
you got to pay your dudes yeah because
it's like you still have to walk through
the door and did you even did you go
down that route at all yeah I mean like
I always grew up just kind of looking at
acting as it's the family business yep
you know what I'm saying so I always
felt that I would go into it
um it's kind of like you know if I had
come from a family where all the you
know my my pencils or were in the
military or some [ __ ] like I probably
would have joined the military you know
what I mean if my whole family was
[ __ ] lawyers or something I might
have been a lawyer I don't know you know
what I mean but I always kind of looked
at it as like you know it's the family
business so it's already kind of like in
my blood and obviously that's a pretty
it'd be a pretty cool thing to be
successful at so I might as well give it
a [ __ ] try you know and I did you
know I mean I still I still act I've
been in a lot of like a notable Series
in films and [ __ ] but
um you know kind of like I'm also uh
involved in other stuff because that's
just kind of like how life how life went
you know it's kind of I realize that
there's other things that I'm interested
in too that I'm passionate about and you
know for a while I was trying to like
pick one thing and like just focus on it
because you know there's there's kind of
like a different schools of thought you
know there's the school of thought that
like you know it takes long enough to
master one thing so you should just pick
one thing and have tunnel vision but I
also kind of I also kind of adhere to
the school of thought of like you could
just [ __ ] do it all you know it's
2022 why not do it all if I want to do
an acting music and you know be an
entrepreneur and run a business why not
and do a podcast it's like [ __ ] it
you're doing it you're about to 2022
yeah we're about to release a podcast
about my co-host right here Josh Dro
called Outlaws gonna call it muscular
yeah
I think it's just going to be called
white guys white guys it's gonna call
two whites in half
this Thursday two jackets called it
jacked and white just what a mess just
what America can't get enough of two
whites and hats these guys are talking
real issues these guys are straight
white and Jack root for them rude just
have my face introduce these guys are
straight white
jacked they like to work out yeah you
think they're just Bros that's just the
tip of the eyes right this Sunday on
Fall watch these guys through the
Simpsons it's jet hands Chad has watch
these guys curl in slow motion and bonus
footage when they spot each other oh did
we mention they have eight inch Cuts hey
whoa wait this that's BT uh late night
today's leg day these guys go ask to
Grass yeah you're talking about flexible
[ __ ] these guys ride a motorcycle
nuts
and they go fast tune in what's his last
name strobe ah Hanks and straw straw
what's your first name again
Josh you guys make up your mind this
Thursday they're strong it up [ __ ] the
testosterone meter hits red hot with
chests
next Tuesday they're gonna work out
without their sure fast enough these
guys don't play around get low let me
spot your hips it's funny because that's
not too far off from like thank you
we're spitballing ideas
pretty much nailed we're in the studio
right now your dad is might be the first
guest yeah I'm watching maybe your dad
doesn't do a lot of interviews I want to
know what's going on I didn't recognize
the guy that's what I mean they're on 30
minutes under the radar I didn't
recognize him for the first 30 minutes I
swear to God [ __ ] right no he was
wearing a fence he was wearing a fat
suit but that was very good your dad
could be an avatar and I would know it's
[ __ ] Tom that'd be some [ __ ] when I
look at Woody on Toy Story I'm like
that's Tom Hanks he puts on a fat suit
Brian's like I'm trying to figure out is
that Tyrese is that Morgan Freeman I
thought it was Megan
maybe let's take a little break from
chatting with our boy I like sports but
I like money too oh my God it's that
time of the year Brian if you like
sports and money and NBA basketball
you're gonna love my friends at
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting part of the NBA new customers
can bet just five dollars on pre-game
money line on any NBA team to win their
game and get 150 in free bets if they do
plus everyone can't combine multiple
bets for a bigger payout with DraftKings
same game parlays you can bet on my nugs
joke it is going off right now bet on
the Lakers you never know you also got
freaking Memphis doing the dang thing
and guess what Maryland sports fans perk
on up draftking Sportsbook is now live
in your state so Maryland you can bet
enjoy download the app right now
Maryland and everybody out there to get
in on the holiday Hoops Action Sign up
with the code fighter place a five
dollar pregame moneyline bet on any NBA
team to win and get 150 in free bets if
they do only a draftking Sportsbook with
the code fighter minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details DraftKings look look I
got my new trophies I'm talking about on
it Alpha Brain I'm talking about the
best supplements on planet Earth I'm
talking about the the literally the kind
of testing they do for Quality yeah but
B if I want like kettlebells and good
protein and warriors you want battle
ropes kettlebells they have all that you
got everything you want but let's say I
like don't love Alpha brand like it's
not for me okay I don't know why you
don't say that I get a refund uh you if
you don't like outreach are necessary if
you don't like Alpha Brain you'll get a
full refund how's that sound oh you can
even go pick it up at Walmart but help
us out here on the show if you go to
audit.com
f-a-t-k you save 10 off the entire site
we're talking about kettlebells steel
Club maces streaming Fitness if you
listen to Chad Hanks and you want to run
through a brick wall let on it help you
out they got half hour workouts online
that are the best workouts I've ever had
half hour don't wait till January first
get your thick ass in shape let my
friend that on it help you out on it.com
f-a-t-k safe temperatures off the entire
site yeah you know with acting too it's
like obviously you've done a million
things right with you've been on some
big shows stuff like that movies but
when your dad's Tom Hanks and anybody
else that's a successful career like
acting's as tough as it gets do you make
any of those sets as a beast like the
level of Entry is a nightmare yeah so by
all so political yeah it's so political
but by all regards you've had a
successful acting career but when your
dad's Tom Hanks it's like Michael Jordan
son I think he played one double a
basketball that ain't gonna cut it when
your dad that people are like oh he's a
failure it's like he was only six two
right it doesn't matter but it's like
your dad who cares about his size but
your dad's you know Michael Jordan so
people are expecting you to NBA is the
least you can do if you're not in seven
All-Star games it was a failure but
that's why so for you you're kind of set
up you know not there's expectations man
like your brother's career is popping
isn't everything King Kong master to
move Jack Black he's great on there he's
in Dexter one of my favorite Seasons but
then you know he's not Tom Hanks yeah
you know it's like it's like a tough
[ __ ] thing to carry man it's a
double-edged sword you know it's like a
it could it could lead you up to a door
but still you have to be the one to walk
through the door big time and if you
haven't paid your dues prior to that
then that's going to be a disaster you
know what I'm saying I'm sure your
family knows like the pitfalls well yeah
I mean that's why like that's why like a
huge misconception is people think that
like my dad would just like call up
someone and be like cast my son in this
movie and like that's just not how it
works right like number one he would
never do that no number two even if he
did like that's not how it works because
it's like first of all you have to be
right for the rule correct you have to
go through the regular process of
auditioning and then calling back and
getting called back so any role that you
book it's like you have to [ __ ] earn
that [ __ ] plus something about them
people I don't realize this thing about
the amount of money like for the movie
that goes into making a movie the
directors all the props
we got to put a song
anything that can work against you
because like I always say this like
people say you know get why don't one of
your big director friends hook you up
hey
here's how it works you write a script
it takes two years three years maybe
yeah then you finally get financing
there's one role that was written
specifically there's a perfect person
for that role and that's that decision
is made by committee you walk in that
room you've got to win that group over
yeah and so I don't give a [ __ ] who you
are you're competing with everybody in
the world everybody in Ireland the best
the best so you go in there they have an
idea the writer the director they The
Producers all have an idea it might be a
different idea but it's the person that
walks in the room and is undeniable but
they all go [ __ ] I didn't he changed my
mind I thought the world was this but it
was it yeah that's the person that gets
there's so many moving pieces yeah but
even when Batman was coming my mom
called me shouldn't know Hollywood she's
like I just don't understand well you're
not the next Batman
click yeah dumbass it's a lot and you
know what's crazy is that sometimes even
if you are undeniable in your
performance that that's not enough
because no so if you might play like for
example like with your honor right I had
a recurring role in your honor with
Brian Cranston on Showtime and the role
I auditioned for was the role of the mob
boss's son who like just gets out of
prison he's kind of like the villain The
Outlaw that's the that's the role I
auditioned for and I and I [ __ ]
crushed it and they were like uh half of
the people wanted me to play that role
but at the end of the day I didn't get
it because I just don't look like the uh
the the actor who plays the father
Michael stolbarg I just don't look like
I could be related right no he just has
dark hair he's got brown eyes you know
what I'm saying I'm like blue eye blonde
hair so at the end of the day they gave
it to someone else just because he
looked physically like he could be more
of that character's son but it was cool
because I still got another rule wasn't
that you yeah another role yeah because
they saw your chops yeah like all right
we'll find something yeah but it was
between me and him and like half the
producers and the directors wanted to
cast me but at the end of the day they
ended up giving each other that's
because that and that can happen for any
I mean I got lucky because they still
offered me a side roll and I was like
[ __ ] awesome and do you call your
when you get these rollers like hit down
be on this that's giving you advice oh
yeah I I asked him for advice all the
time yeah you should all the time
and I'm actually I'm actually uh about
to release uh uh an online course it's a
master class on not just like the
fundamentals of acting but like the
politics of like how to actually break
into the entertainment industry and
actually get your foot in the door I'm
about to release that it's on it's an
online course and I'm gonna include
basically everything that my dad has
taught me in it do you have a problem
from my friend Brian what's it called
yeah I need some help well my daughter
called the Actor's Advantage so my
daughter's put a good word for you Dad
yeah
my daughter's 14. he's dying to do but
she's my daughter's into theaters I I
pay for Theater Camp in New York and and
she she'll have an audition or you know
for the school play or whatever and I'm
like you know done this for a little
while I might be able to offer some
advice I might be having it right not
having it well even Tony Hawk said he
was like you know his son does a
skateboarding you say he walked in all
these friends who are like sponsoring
their their skateboarders they're
watching this and he walks in the
kitchen and he's like they don't even
pay attention to me because I walk in
the kitchen they're watching this video
this kid doing like a 360 and something
else and they're all this is insane and
saying his dad's Tony Hawk and he goes
what are you guys watching he goes oh I
actually created that movie like that
get out of here he's like okay he's like
the kid doesn't want it yeah that's a
kids no yeah you gotta you definitely I
utilize that you know like uh I utilize
all my dad's knowledge and I've you know
asked him I've been on set like in my
trailer like you know right then and
there like hell like asking him
questions and he's always been there
giving me some bad signals he always
really helps me align my perceptions
because sometimes the advice that he
gives is just really [ __ ] simple like
honestly one of the best pieces of
advice he's ever given me is like really
the best thing you could do to prepare
for any role is just [ __ ] show up on
time know your lines and treat everyone
with respect wow that'll get you a long
way you know and it's really just that
simple because we over complicate things
and we we get so stressed out in our
heads about trying to be perfect but at
the end of the day it's just like show
up on time [ __ ] know your lines like
the back of your hand and [ __ ] just
be polite to everyone
by the way that's exactly right because
you're it's such a collaborative process
you want to work with people that you
like that's right you want to work with
people you know even like Special Forces
teams like whether it's Delta or SEAL
Team Six you know you're like what are
the what's the criteria you have to be
these big natural athletes and stuff
when you actually talk to the dudes that
have been there do you know what they
say a lot of times yeah they they'll say
they'll be like well no there are a lot
of guys that are that are really you
know they're badasses Specialists but
you want the dude you like that you can
trust that's a great teammate yeah he
may not be as strong he may not be as
great a shot and all that but that's the
dude you want on Mission
that's anything special forces but
whether you're acting it's a team to get
a project done even businesses yeah you
know apple with uh you know Steve Jobs
when they start in that garage there's
like a team like it was just a team and
reputation you know if you're an [ __ ]
then you know it catches up with you
yeah if you're doing big movies and
people are buying tickets they're gonna
put up with that pre-madonna ship as
soon as that movie eats [ __ ] you're the
first one you're done yeah but like then
but if if you're a pleasure to work
around then it's the opposite it works
you know you could have a bad movie and
people are still going to want to [ __ ]
with you but you know but I found that
though that the highest the highest
level people are always just out of
people that I've met in any field of
acting or whatever just the most A-list
people that I've ever met are always the
[ __ ] coolest the most humble and the
most humble the most down to earth they
don't act they don't have any
superiority they'll talk to anybody just
like with with the same amount of
respect that's that's what I've always
noticed it's always like the B and C
Level people that have the [ __ ]
massive egos yup yup yup and so when
with the acting stuff obviously your
dad's helped me there when he saw you do
like white boy summer which I love
have you ever seen this before oh yeah
it's funny we played it I loved it great
and it is a white boy's uh Christmas it
was a white Christmas found white boy
Christmas you don't usually you don't
usually draw out love I love that
long nights of that video anyways but um
this was in Venice too
ladies
it's just it's a white boy with a bunch
of chocolate is that an AK-47 on your
side
[Laughter]
oh no that's in your shorts um but are
you uh that's a bazooka that's a bazooka
but like when your dad sees this does he
understand it is he cool with it or is
he like white boy some no they were they
were cool with the they were cool with
the they're they're they're supportive
man they were like what what uh stop
talking about let's stop they're so
detached from like like that kind of
current those kind of current events
that it's like they're not really aware
of of what's popular or what's not so
they're just like you know if they if
they're like if they see that like they
were like oh that's that that's just
like anything that cardi B does okay
cool you know what I mean like good
shape my dad still doesn't understand
what I do he told somebody my brother's
with him at lunch the other day uh
someone was like hey someone moved to
Hollywood right it's going well for him
he's like yeah what's he doing I think
he's like an Instagram influencer my
brother's like Jesus Christ when I shot
my first special Showtime big deal my
dad didn't come two days later he cut
flies out here we're walking with my
grandkids with his grandkids and we're
walking down the mall because I forgot
to ask how'd your speech go the other
night
how did your speech go hey yeah get it
[ __ ] right
play going
so I'm doing like what are you talking
about my dad's old heads unless it's on
like HBO or Comedy Central they don't
Dateline they got your speech going 60
Minutes hey dude I didn't do a TED Talk
Phillips my dad's 82 years old Dan
Rather is looking on my special my
father's 82 years old and every bit of
250 pounds 6'4 and and he's walking down
the steps today I'm on the phone and I
just hear go go go go go go go go go go
go
[ __ ] fell down the stairs into a
plant into a table broke the table glass
everywhere and he's lying on the he's I
thought he was [ __ ] dead he's lying
against the [ __ ] wall like that right
and I go and I I'm like I literally go I
gotta call you back I run you okay you
okay like that I reached at him and he
goes like this he's down like this he
goes yeah
but he like I was all panicked and he
goes yeah
get out of here and then my mother broke
his back my mother my mother goes we
should go to the to the hospital that's
your mom I'm not going to the hospital
walks back upstairs I fell because you
said something and I turned around you
know how old is he 82. wow
I check it with him like he's watching
his computer with you right now yeah I
go you're all right and he goes
my mother said that my mother goes he
won't notice what he's eating I go but
what the [ __ ] is this like he'll eat all
yeah you respect it but you're also like
is he on the Spectrum a little bit right
I told you we were in we're almost in a
plane crash he already he wasn't a plane
crash but he's flying his plane and the
plane's going boom and my dog hit the
ceiling I'm like Jesus Christ and my
father looks at me and he goes it's not
a bad way to die
dead serious I'm like
there's dad's Savage he's a nut Savage
eats bananas with pills yeah yeah still
still [ __ ] I told you it was with the
peel well he was he was watching a game
and didn't notice holy [ __ ] and I go my
mother goes you're eating with the peel
he goes what I'm like how the [ __ ] I
missed I don't know to respect it or is
that peanut butter crazy [ __ ] I do this
joke in my stand-up but it's a true
story we're in a [ __ ] car we're in a
we're in a in my car and there's a
hornet it's not a yellow jacket you know
those Hornets that live either like in
your attic or they're they're in the
ground the ones with the three abdomens
and the [ __ ] fur they have like Ninja
Turtle ABS yeah they live alone for the
reason they're wet yeah
[Music]
yes and they'll get you in the face oh
so I I literally see this [ __ ] thing
and I'm like oh my God I can't get out
fast enough it's like a prism color yeah
yeah yes my father with his giant
[ __ ] Farm Boy finger big dick beater
this ghost goes like this grabs it and
goes
it broke its neck and just broke its
back and the thing was like [ __ ] you you
know like I I tell the story but it's
all true and it crossed but he [ __ ]
killed it and then your dad eat him he's
doing this he's going like this he goes
and I go that stinks I think sting you
and he goes probably
they're coming from a different clock
From a Different Cloth my grandpa he
would eat [ __ ] uh you know like a
drumstick a chicken yeah he would eat it
the whole thing alone and everything he
would eat the he would eat cherries holy
wouldn't spit out the pits he'd eat the
pits yeah Savage
the smartest way to go but they didn't
leave [ __ ] to waste and do what your
grandfather was eating entertainment no
no he was he was he was my mom's dad so
he was from Bulgaria oh yeah yeah of
course yeah he was from chicken yeah you
know that's hardcore my grandfather's a
snack on rocks
oh yeah he actually played soccer with
rocks growing up yeah he's just a big
boulder yeah they would just kick her
off doing scissor kicks and [ __ ] I knew
my dad was tough when I was a kid
because he was never afraid of any dog
he didn't give a [ __ ] about any dog
you're probably like that a little bit
but like ultimately he knew he was big
enough to kill the dog like the dog's
gonna bite you but in his mind he was
like I'll kill that dog yeah me I'm
afraid of dogs I don't have the bone
structure
but you're having hands full if it's
like a golden retriever or something
Rottweiler you got a problem oh that's
no doubt yeah yeah I'm saying like even
a wiener dogs can give you some friends
not with him he'd see a dog and be like
dogs and he'd be like we're gonna go
through that field and I'm like have you
ever been attacked by a dog
I've been bit by a dog but I wore a
sleeve I wore so I was in Afghanistan I
never had to actually fight a dog no no
you yeah hey have you I have before not
your [ __ ] hold on
I was a bit by a real dog I had to
defend myself against a dog yeah me too
what's yours okay so how old are you
first of all 32. okay I don't know how
old was I yeah oh I was 17. okay that's
all yeah exactly yeah so okay like kind
of what I was saying earlier eventually
I got in trouble I got sent to this
Wilderness Program went to Utah for a
year this thing I was in this school
that's where I finished my high school
credits blah blah that's a long story
anyway while I was there boys club in
Utah yeah we had to do like community
service like you know what I'm saying
it's like manual labor [ __ ] like that so
like one of the things one of the yeah
but they kept it they kept us they kept
us divided they kept using haters right
so so they made us do community service
so one of the things we had to do was go
down these dog kennels in Salt Lake City
and like clean up [ __ ] and like do all
this [ __ ] right so one of the chores we
had to do was like walk the dogs the
dogs are all it's like they're all
cooped up losing their minds in this
[ __ ] you know it's like a dog
prisoners so so they let us pick a dog
and we have to block it right and I'm
like 17 and I want to be all badass so I
picked the like the most ripped [ __ ]
pit bull in the place right and and the
the people that ran over they were like
are you sure you don't want that one and
it was like some little you know tiny
I'm like no I want that one I'm like 17
years old I'm like 150 pounds like like
you know I see the pit bull rap videos
give me that so yeah and it was vicious
like it was all already like barking and
losing its mind in the [ __ ] kennel
right I'm like no I want that one like
okay like this is like the roughest dog
we have I'm like nobody walks it I don't
want to back down now so right so so
they so they give me the dog to walk and
we're all walking in a line to go take
it out of the building to go like walk
it outside right so everyone's going
around the corner and I'm the last one
so the last person goes around the
corner and as I'm about to go around the
corner I'm alone the dog [ __ ] turns
on me and starts attacking me right it
starts lunging for me like literally
trying to [ __ ] kill me so I got it on
the leash right so all I can do is I'm
swinging the leash because it's a
lunging for me it's like full-on jumping
through the air lunging for me so I'm
I'm swinging I'm yanking the leash
midair so the dogs
so but what it starts doing is it
figures it out so it starts it starts
biting the leash hell yeah little little
bit so the slack is getting shorter and
shorter so I'm yanking the leash but
it's biting a little up and up on the
leash until it gets right up on my
[ __ ] hand right until the dog is
hanging on right up against my fist and
it's about to Lunge one more time but
this time there's no more room it's
gonna [ __ ] like bite my [ __ ] head
off so I just full on just punch this
[ __ ] dog in the face as hard as I
could right right I just punched the
[ __ ] dog as hard as I could in the
face and then it froze up and then I was
like you good I'm like you good chill
chill the [ __ ] out like it was just kind
of backed off a little bit I'm like all
right let's go but I really like I I was
I really wanted to call for help no like
because everyone was gone the whole time
I wanted to be like help help the dump
it on you I couldn't I didn't say
anything because I didn't want to be
embarrassed because the Dude literally
pressed me he was like are you sure you
want this I was like yeah I got it so I
but I [ __ ] you not from that by the end
of the the walk that dog respected me
your best friend they loved me I could I
literally could put my face up to it and
pet it and it was completely fine yeah
it's like Avatar right those dragons you
gotta connect with them you got to break
them in I'm Gonna Catch so much heat
from the animals no you're not if it's a
pit bull you gotta I know a guy who used
to show him what's up I know a guy who
dealt with uh problem dogs like that the
first thing you do is take them put them
on their back and get on top of them and
hold them there until they come yeah
yeah my story nowhere near is cool and I
wish I went first but I'll follow that I
was like 10 and this kid uh in his
backyard these kids were mean to me they
bullied me but they invited me I'm like
hell yeah I'll go with you guys to your
house and play and his house got a tree
in the backyard got struck by lightning
and he's like go check out the tree it's
sick man I got struck by light and
Michael yeah and they're like you go
first I'm like okay so I'm walking and
then I get to this backyard and I shut
the gate I'm like what the hell is going
on here I see this big dog coming around
the corner oh no no no no if you think
about it now it's like hey that duck
could have killed me yes morons what
kind of dog I forget it was like this
rottweiler lab it was a big [ __ ] dog
and I'm like tender so I just see him
just remember barking I'm like oh [ __ ]
and I didn't want him to steal the money
maker the Big Wang it's like he was
right like this so I turned last second
dude he grabbed onto my oh he went to
bite you no he bit me oh he bit my ass
tore my ass up lit my ass up damn and I
climbed over the fence but I got home I
had to go to the doctors which was part
in front of my mom they took me to the
emergency room they had to give me the
Tetanus shot because the dog's mouth or
whatever in my ass the biggest needle
you've ever seen
probably rabies yeah I don't know but
but by the way like if you've ever put a
sleeve on or inside I felt house how
hard that bite is yeah
no no
six seven pound dog and the dog came and
I was like no I've seen the video we
watched the video one time it sounds
anticlimactic
oh my God this thing's crazy everyone's
off I stuck my thing it goes like this
but no but I never had a dog like that
it was pulling and trying to shake and I
was like okay okay your dad would watch
angle bad acting
this dog's attacking me well in [ __ ]
Dove David off when we're in Afghanistan
doing stand-up [ __ ] he goes we're
gonna go get bit by dogs I go what we
get bit by dogs so they put us in a bite
suit but no helmet and the guy goes just
go run and I go what do you mean the
dogs these are giants fall down giant
Dutch Shepherd I need a he goes they
won't bite you in the head they don't
like head I'm like but
this area is not protected sir it's like
just run man because now I'm with
soldiers I don't want to be a [ __ ] and
I'm running and they're like stay stop
stop and play acting and then [ __ ]
let that thing go man bit me right here
decided to bite me right there and I'm
like ah and it knocks me down and then I
do this and it grabs me here don't
freaked out bit him on the hand but he
had a glove on no it wasn't enough get
this [ __ ] wolf off get this wolf off
did it hurt to you it hurts I'm telling
you dude when you feel the pressure you
go oh that's why when it bites you you
shut down because all the nerves shut
down they will break your bones they'll
bite right through you that's a Malinois
I don't know what the [ __ ] a pitbull
would do it's a whole different story
they're just different and they're so
strong yeah what's up with them they're
just all jacked well that's why how do
you get that Jack without working out
they're just exist that way look that
that's why I went there you know most
jacked vegan in the world is a gorilla
you look at a girl you're like how in
the [ __ ] yeah like three percent body
fat just eat [ __ ] leaves it's like
they don't even have to build the muscle
it's already there it's just that yeah
you know what the strongest bite is
huh a hippo right now crocodiles oh yeah
yeah so these guys are in Australia and
also the saltwater crocodile the guys in
Australia three guys mammals uh isn't a
Jaguar not compared to uh no but I'm
saying that's that's you know mammals
maybe but but I'm saying mammals I think
it's a gorilla I don't think it's a
Silverback but but the saltwater
crocodile this [ __ ] 10 strongest
animal bite force in the world too
you'll see it These Guys these guys are
[ __ ] uh these guys are are swimming
and their friend just disappeared they
didn't hear anything he just went like
you know how it just he got taken that
quickly [ __ ] Joe was right hippopotamus
number one
number two gorilla number three
stupid hyenas dead second to last on a
grizzly bear [ __ ] dead last great white
number one yeah great white number one
oh gray we call them the old whites yeah
all gray I mean yeah hippos are the most
lethal animal in Africa more people die
from hippos now correct uh mosquitoes
number one but I feel you oh yeah oh
coming in with me I'm just trying to
drop something
mosquitoes yeah man we're talking animal
what do you do for a workout let's get
the [ __ ] let's get down to what
really matters this has all been
[ __ ] talk let's get down to high
yeah cause I'd love to hear your workout
routine
like box I'm trying to get my boxing
skills back up a little bit it's a good
workout yeah it is it is now you just
got a new Whip stay in the conversation
over here you just got a new whip yeah
good for you man yeah is that that
Ferrari no that's mine right I've driven
yeah what happened I saw your car I
thought yours was green you have a green
one no there's a black one the black one
they're like the old rims yeah but it's
a it's a you can see the engine yeah
that's mine that's the 430. I've had it
for a year yeah I don't think it's very
pretty we don't know cars you drive a
Tesla no I don't think
that's not a pretty car
oh papa you're so sweet
what are you driving he has a Urus I got
the lambo truck
and when you post that it's always would
you post that stuff you're doing for
inspiration because I'm sure people like
oh show off or whatever how do you feel
about that yeah I mean it is for
inspiration I mean you know it's the
best SUV on the market I've had them all
I have one of those favorite SUV I love
it really I love it okay not for you
right porque hey I I can be into cars if
the guys are in the Cars one like why
can't it be cool
hey guys what what do you got under that
hood I don't know how to talk to you
post that like motivation motivation
well it's like this you know like I
started I started my uh the self-mastery
program
a year ago is on January 1st right so
that what that is it's it's online
Fitness Nutrition and mindset coaching I
mean you came on Kingston yeah we talked
about a dairy we talked about it then
yes right when we launched it so I
assign people their ideal training plan
custom to their body their nutrition
plan custom to their body and I hold
Zoom calls once a week where we can
speak directly one-on-one or in a group
right so there's different packages but
that's where we get into the deeper
stuff the mindset stuff the motivational
stuff
um I started this a year ago you know if
you follow me or you know watch my story
every single day I'm up at 4 45 in the
morning I go to I do a hundred burpees
while it's still before the sun's coming
up I go through my morning process my
morning routine I'm in the gym usually
about seven a.m with Josh right here
um I'm lifting weights a little apple
bottom
um and then for the rest of the time
y'all's in the room because you got an
ass on you
so I I this is every single day you know
every single day like I I if you follow
me that you see right so it's like when
I started this program
um I was just you know I had been
basically a couple months out of rehab
right because I had I had been sober for
five years then during the whole white
boy summer [ __ ] I was not sober where
could you be you know it was here what
was your white boy summer you can't pee
no you can't be yeah it was crazy man
don't be a pusher what was your drug of
choice if you don't mind Coke really ooh
that booger sugar the devil devil
man it's awesome so it was a good time
though for a little bit let's not
hey no don't start like reminding us
until it's not you know what I'm saying
yeah until you do too much I basically
you know went crazy I got to the point
where it was just [ __ ] really bad I
was like okay I have to change my life I
got clean again you know a couple uh and
while I was getting clean and getting my
life back together I just you know
really really uh like fell in love with
just like Fitness and working out and
just just mostly just so uh for the
mental aspect you know just not not just
improving myself physically but keeping
myself in a positive state of mind also
the endorphins really exactly just the
natural height when you're trying to
overcome a dictionary or whatever break
any sort of bad habits it's really not
good enough to just try to drop your bad
habits you have to replace them with
good habits otherwise you're just going
to obsess about you know whatever your
substance or drug of choice is you're
just going to obsess about it even more
because something's missing but
nothing's been gained yeah so you know
you really have to you have to
substitute your bad habits with good
habits so that's what I did I started
working out just like a [ __ ] freak
like every day non-stop just really
became obsessed with it and then I got
my nutrition dialed in I found out what
my macros were which really makes all
the difference because like your gains
ABS whatever is all made in the kitchen
like you can't out work a poor diet if
you're working you could be working your
ass off in the gym every single [ __ ]
day if you're not eating the proper
macros you don't know your proper
nutrition you're not going to make any
[ __ ] progress that's like that it's
like it's literally 90 of it so I found
out what my actual macros were I did my
research on all that [ __ ] I was already
working out every day I was posting it
uh mostly just you know just for
accountability because I wanted to show
people you know like hey I'm really
doing this every single [ __ ] day and
it was also to hold myself accountable
because I didn't want to fall off and
skip a day because I was trying to keep
myself that consistent right so I was
putting pressure on myself well while I
was doing that people were hitting me up
and asking me like hey man like they
noticed that you know my body was
changing I was starting to like you know
get in better shape so people were
hitting me up asking me tips this and
that you know what should I do so I
figured well if I'm if I'm going to be
already committed to working out every
day I might as well come up with a way
to monetize it so entrepreneur yeah so I
launched my program and keep in mind
okay so at that time you know I'm out of
rehab I'm [ __ ] coming I'm building my
life back up from the [ __ ] you know
shambles so I was like I'm like [ __ ]
broke you know what I'm saying when I
started this thing but I just started a
little fast forward a year later you
know what I'm saying the business has
been going so well I'm in a [ __ ]
Lambo so yeah I'm posting this [ __ ] to
so to show people what can really be
achieved when you drop all your [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] bad habits and just
[ __ ] commit to your own
self-improvement in your what was your
personality
right now what was your turn I want to
invite the three of us to a cocaine
party look at these noses
it's a good looking Beach
don't don't put amount of cocaine in
front of us
he's still got his youthful looks he's a
good look I've never done cooking ever
in my life are you serious respect
um
you already do in Vegas
that's right no um what what do you
remember I'm always fascinated with like
because so much of this oh it feels good
so much of this heartfelt Moment by the
way we came out of the closet a couple
minutes ago and uh yeah man I don't do
Coke but I do now
did you say Coke I thought we were
talking about [ __ ] me too
uh Liz I was a [ __ ] addict I went down
some dark places that's right if you
take my program giving up Cox R Us it's
only good
sucking dude all right I'm sorry sorry
go ahead God he opened up and now you
bring coffee I'm so sorry dude but what
do you I can't help it do you remember
because I always believe like when you
actually make that decision right that
real decision to go sober like there's
that The Rock bottoms yeah something
happens where you make that decision do
you remember what that switch was what
was Rock Bottom yeah I mean basically it
was just I had been partying my ass off
for all the [ __ ] white boy summer you
know what three months yeah how long's a
white boy summer that's what it was
about three months standard summer well
cocaine standard summer that the good
thing about cocaine see with alcohol you
can be an alcoholic for 30 years you
wake up with no resume you know it's
like it's a slower burn blow is
devastating very quickly it's like
where'd my house go you know so in that
sense you can it's especially is pure
Pablo Escobar [ __ ] yeah am I right oh no
you don't don't talk about don't talk to
us about cocaine you don't know about it
I don't but I would never do it now
because the the fentanyl yeah there are
kits on Amazon you can use it back to
you what was it what was it was it more
inspiration or was it fear that caused
these or you don't want to be a loser
well I mean basically I knew that I I
really had to get my [ __ ] together so I
Was preparing to [ __ ] you know go to
rehab and clean myself up again but
without any intention of like staying
sober just to like get myself back on my
feet right and take a little break well
I had a show out in Vegas
I was supposed to go out for a night a
live show yeah I was supposed a
performance I was supposed to go out for
a night and then you know check myself
in a rehab
um the next day well I went outside to
show I went to the party afterwards I
didn't leave the party for three days
and three nights and didn't sleep I
didn't eat anything I was just [ __ ]
going white boy yeah for three days and
three nights literally like 72 hours
yeah it doesn't sound fun at all yeah by
the end of that I was just like full-on
[ __ ] it's not fun you know it's not
fun by the end yeah
it's just eat your
it's you just lose your mind you know
what I mean just like off yourself not
just also not productive
I mean it depends on
depends on what you're trying to [ __ ]
do but you know keep going
um but uh yeah dude I mean apart from
just you know doing that much drugs I
mean just the sleep deprivation aspect
the lack of nutrition you know not
drinking any water you know it's like
that [ __ ] is enough to just basically
send you into a [ __ ] full-blown
psychosis where you just don't even know
what's real and what's not anymore you
know you're just on your gone you know
this [ __ ] Elvis has [ __ ] left the
building you know what I mean so now
they left the building yeah I was just
you know I was yeah like I was gone so
that was enough for like to scare me
straight and be like holy [ __ ] you know
if I don't make a change like a drastic
change then uh like I'm
[ __ ] headed towards a disaster I mean
it already is a disaster but I knew like
if I didn't make a change that I was
gonna end up like
uh like Kurt Cobain do it
basically like dealing with a
consequence that I couldn't come back
from if it wasn't just [ __ ] dying
like losing my life [ __ ] or just getting
caught in this situation or making a
stupid ass [ __ ] decision you know
when I'm in that like state of mind I
just knew something bad was was coming
and it was coming fast like if I didn't
make it if I didn't make us yeah like
impending doom you know so if I didn't
if I didn't make a serious change so
that was just it I just said you know
[ __ ] never again and now because I
you know I have two young boys I can't
imagine like if they went down that road
you as a dad I'd feel like like I gotta
fix this yeah I'm Gonna Fly that to
Vegas and find them amongst these chicks
and the white boy Summer video and take
them and make them better I'm sure for
your family your brother you know your
friends they're like we got to do
something here but there's not much they
can do huh did they try yeah I mean this
is it's like you said there's there's
not much you can do like even even my
friends were like you know they just
were kind of like [ __ ] dude you know
you're you're an adult yeah you know
sometimes you're gonna learn this
because your kids are young but my
daughter now is 14. and one of the
things that's maddening is that you lose
a lot of control over your children
because they're their own people and
they make their own decisions and
they're going to make their own mistakes
in the basement give it up ah yeah no
Freedom yeah but all that [ __ ] is really
just dealing with pain in a bad way you
know yes at the end at the end of the
yeah at the end of the day
people that are you know like drug
addicts and whatnot like for the most
part they're not bad people you know
they're they're really good they're not
like they they're human you know at the
end of the day and I have this
realization while I was you know in that
state because you know I could find
myself in some pretty shady places but
at the end of the day I would look
around and be like you know none of
these people are are bad people we're
just dealing with we're just people that
that are in pain that are dealing with
our pain in the wrong ways we're just
dealing with our pain in the wrong way
so like with my program in the
self-mastery program is all about is
that we need to face our pain and
channel it for our own growth right so I
mean that's what literally on a physical
level on a literal level I mean that's
what exercise is you're putting your
body in physical pain right but it's
pain that is building you it's making
you stronger it's making you healthier
so and that's just on a on the on a
literal physical level what's happening
physiologically in your body but it's
also happening on a mental and spiritual
level because as you start to improve
and you as you start to improve and get
stronger physically and you're
channeling that Pain by putting it to
work right because because most people
who are who are addicts it's like we
have all these emotions we have all
these feelings going on and we're
dealing with it by numbing it or running
to drugs we're not addressing it we're
not addressing it so we have to address
that we basically just have to take it
out in the [ __ ] gym period you got to
take all that energy out in the gym the
energy that angst and that anxiety or
regret or depression like it's not going
anywhere you have to literally do
something with it what you have to do
with it is you have to literally put it
to [ __ ] work you have to put it to
work it'll work that [ __ ] off in the gym
and as you start to do that as you start
to get stronger as your body starts to
change you start to literally look and
feel exactly how you want to how you
truly want to a mental shift occurs also
where you level up [ __ ] mentally you
you're the way you start to talk to
yourself is different you know that that
feeling of that angst and that anxiety
that no longer becomes your status quo
that no longer becomes the place where
you live it might still come I'm back it
might still rear its head but but more
and more as you progress the state that
you live in is you know what I [ __ ]
got this I can't be [ __ ] stopped all
this [ __ ] happened for a reason to bring
me where I am today the opportunities
that your future becomes clear you see
all the all the blessings you're
grateful you're living a state of
gratitude a state of empowerment that
becomes your Norm right the more that
you put that [ __ ] to work that that
becomes your Norm gratitude gratitude
opens the door to infinite intelligence
you're gonna be the poster boy for Rehab
because most correct me if I'm wrong
most rehab I think the success rate's
like two percent well I it's bring it up
Jen you want to bet on rehab yeah rehab
no I mean it's that's right it's
terrible I saw yesterday the success
rate for any you know drug and alcohol
abuse is terrible but that's because
people don't have but but that's because
like this is what I'm saying is that it
requires more like a like an ongoing
thing right like
like I'm a big like uh but let's
complete it yeah that's like 71 700 in
the beginning then it was like drops
just after a few months 61 then at the
end of six months like 46. so you know
age age actually is the one thing that a
lot of people outgrow their addiction
with age this is really weird but uh and
they don't know why but so you you could
be a very bad drug addict very bad
alcoholic if you can stay alive long
enough believe it or not you you tend to
it's not the majority it actually is
there's no way yeah I promise the the
age thing is actually something that
you'll see old addicts who no longer
have that but barring that you want to
do that before you hit a certain age you
want to get you know and well I think
it's an ongoing thing right gratitude
and things like that those things are
keeping your State of Mind standing sort
of century at the door of your mind to
make sure the wrong thoughts don't it's
all state of mind I mean everything is
mental yeah like my your mindset and
your mentality is everything yeah right
it's like like
especially especially when you're first
getting sober right because if you're
first getting started trying to change
your life your your state of mind at any
given moment is so [ __ ] volatile and
that's why most people don't stay sober
is because they're they don't have any
stability in their own [ __ ] mental
health yeah right like so the second you
know something gets a little too painful
or harder they get a little too
uncomfortable they just run right back
to it they destroy their life they get
sober again and then they [ __ ] it's
just a vicious cycle because it's one
thing to get sober it's another thing to
[ __ ] stay sober right most people can
get sober a [ __ ] million [ __ ]
times but they can't [ __ ] stay sober
because they're not focusing on their
[ __ ] mentality and they think that
they can Master the mentality just from
thinking you can't you can't [ __ ]
master your mentality just from thinking
you can't think your way into a positive
that's an action you can only act your
way into positive thinking period and
this is the problem with [ __ ] you
know a lot of stuff I have nothing bad
to say about any 12-step programs
because I think they're really helpful
and I have nothing bad to say about
rehabs but but uh but just you know my
personal opinion is that I think a lot
of
a lot of these uh programs don't work
because they're not putting any emphasis
on your physicality
like you cannot uh you cannot Overlook
the importance of [ __ ] fitness and
health you can't Overlook the importance
of people think it's just superficial
because it's people think that people go
to the gym or workout are just
superficial because they only they just
care about how they look it's not about
that it's not about that it's literally
putting in the work so that you can live
each day physically feeling your best
that you are living as your best self
everybody if they look everybody feels
if you feel like you need to lose 10 15
pounds or put on [ __ ] 10 15 pounds of
muscle to really feel like that best
version of yourself then [ __ ] do it
do it you need to do it you absolutely
need to do it because that that feeling
that gift that you have to earn is
what's waiting for you and that's
actually the high that you're seeking
the high that you're seeking when you go
get drunk or go do drugs whatever of
feeling like good about yourself from a
substance is a false High the true high
is just living and breathing every day
is like looking in the mirror and man
say damn I look good I feel good I'm
walking different I'm talking different
I'm carrying myself in a different way
that that can only come through putting
in the [ __ ] work period so all these
it's the action it's the [ __ ] action
that counts you can't just you can't
think your way out of this [ __ ] you have
to act your way out of it I don't mean
to surprise you but this is an
intervention Oh no
you're you're drinking ways in boring
talk affects me in the following ways
when you when you put in your Invisalign
it affects me the following ways one
more month it's triggering one more
month you [ __ ] seven years you need
to go on business line and I can't wait
because I'm gonna
but the whole point is it's not about
how you look it's about how you [ __ ]
feel yeah I guarantee you if somebody
who who's who's you know they've never
like given themselves that chance before
of actually like putting in the work
getting themselves in just their best
physical shape right because it's not
about reaching any standard I'm not
saying that you have to look like a
bodybuilder you have to look like a
[ __ ] Instagram model right it's just
about being at your Peak physical state
that you've ever experienced in your
life right it's just about it's not
about perfection it's about progress
right right so it's not about reaching
some [ __ ] standard of what you're
supposed to look like it's just waking
up knowing hey I'm in the best shape
I've ever been when you wake up knowing
I'm in the best shape I've ever [ __ ]
been I'm at my Peak I'm at my physical
[ __ ] Peak that I've ever experienced
in life it doesn't matter if you're in
your 50s or in your if you're in your
[ __ ] 20s right because you can
achieve that no matter how old you are
but when you reach that point where
you're at your physical peak and you
know that each day you're improving more
and more and more that is the [ __ ]
mentality shift that's when the flip
gets switched in your mentality when you
feel so fulfilled that you no longer
have the desire to go get high so is
that that's the only way to overcome it
is that then replacing the pleasure of
drugs with with the pleasure of
self-restriction and exercise right so
you're kind of like you're you're taking
the pleasure I would I would I would
think the pleasure
I wouldn't say it's it's replacing
pleasure with pleasure I would say it's
replacing pleasure with fulfillment
because pleasure is like a fleeting
thing like pleasure is what is what
we're chasing when we're [ __ ] when we
do a light of coke yeah and that's what
my men that's what my mentor Wes Watson
says purpose over pleasure that's like
his whole that's huge thing you know
what I'm saying purpose over pleasure
yeah and that's not my phrase that's
from what I didn't coin that [ __ ]
I love that did you get more spiritual
as a result did you did you find
absolutely yeah that's what happened go
to church no I don't go to church uh
pray yeah I pray that counts I'm
spiritual I mean I still do consider
myself a Christian I was baptized Greek
Orthodox I Believe In Christ you know
who's Greek my mom oh [ __ ] yeah but I'm
just not super religious but uh but I'm
extremely spiritual and this this is I
mean that I say the the spirituals is
the third part that come because it
starts off with our it's mind body and
soul it starts off with the body starts
off with our physicality we have to
change that we have to be growing in
doubt once that happens the Mind
naturally follows suit the state of the
Mind improves when the state of the mind
and the body are both
synced that's when the spiritual is
birthed and truly we can live our lives
in that gratitude there's nothing more
spiritual than just being grateful it
doesn't matter if you're an atheist or
whether you believe in a higher power or
not the goal the spiritual goal the
spiritual aspect is just living in
[ __ ] gratitude who's your Mentor Wes
Watson what who is he he's the he's the
guy who started all this and he's who
showed me this he's he he taught me how
to speak he went to his own battle right
yeah I mean I've been I have been
following him for years and he really
really uh impacted my life just from
just from setting the example so uh
um he's the one who started all this
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying man I just
I I just I just followed suit I followed
his example I got on his program and it
changed my voice homeboy's Jack he was
in prison gangs
was he in jail yeah you guys have never
you guys should really you guys really
need to look him up get him on the
podcast yeah you should get him on the
floor yeah that that dude is Jack but so
he spent time on the inside his story is
really tattoos would say yeah he's on
YouTube check out his YouTube channel 10
10 years but basically wow
uh I had started following him right
when he got out of prison
um and when he got out of prayer I mean
he was fresh out of prison you know what
I'm saying and that was like four years
ago and I've literally over the past
four every single day I mean he's up
he's up at [ __ ] 245 but he does the
same exactly like how like like how I'm
saying I do the same [ __ ] every day I'll
wake up early I post my workout I got
that from him I got it from he was
already doing that uh and I he hasn't
missed a day in the whole four years
I've been following him in the four
years I've been following I saw him
going from just getting out of prison
not having anything to now he's like a
multi multi multi-millionaire amazing I
think he lives because you you had a
divorce star you had something to yeah I
mean I literally saw it right happened
right in front of my [ __ ] eyes every
single day he hasn't been in L.A San
Diego so I saw I saw it happen every
single [ __ ] day right in front of my
eyes I mean he just moved in like a
[ __ ] Resort his his house is so
[ __ ] huge he's got it every [ __ ]
like luxury car in the book I literally
saw her right in front of my [ __ ]
eyes after 10 years in prison yeah and
what do you do what do you go to prison
for I mean I can't remember but he he
tells a story he he tells a story
connect us I'll connect you guys
yeah because I I find that so
fascinating you know like I always say
anything that bad that happens to you
your job is to orchestrate your life so
that you look back on it for whatever it
is a year or five years and say I
wouldn't have changed it I wouldn't have
changed that because I am who I am now
and I like who I am now and I didn't
like who I was then you know
you're an inspiration chat you know what
I'm saying I think you're starting your
own podcast anyone who listen to this if
that doesn't put you on the right track
and hopefully give some people some
motivation you know I think they can go
well for you man thank you yeah I'm just
passing it on yeah I love that man
when's the next when's the first podcast
dropping dude uh we don't have a set
date yet but it's gonna be you'll know
right around it's right around the
corner I don't think I don't think
you'll feel it Mr Tom Hanks has done any
podcast right I don't know we reached
out to him and he didn't get back to us
let's go to current events Jen uh can we
do fan questions first oh yeah we had a
bunch dude over 500 [ __ ] yeah let's do
it yeah but we only picked or Tom picked
three out of the five or whatever your
boy Tom picked the three yeah
all right so first one's from Antonio
Roland hey guys it's Tony from Philly my
question to chat would be would he be
interested in a celebrity boxing match
and who would he want to fight and
Antonio's suggesting Andrew Tate no and
um yeah I would be interested in a
celebrity boxing match that's kind of
why it is well I mean I want to be ready
for it if either if they ever get a
great offer for that you know what I'm
saying I don't know if I as far as like
fighting like Andrew Tate or Jake Paul I
would want to fight somebody first and
foremost that was like who who it was
their first fight yeah someone's
fighting Andrew Taylor on your level and
he that dude is like a he's I mean he's
a [ __ ] multiple world champion yeah
so it's like uh
I would stop that fight and jump in no I
mean him and Jake and bull and uh also
uh I've spoken to both those dudes and
they're really [ __ ] cool Andrew Tate
actually helped me out a lot yeah
they're both good dudes uh connected
with Andrew Tate before he got kicked
off Instagram and uh he actually helped
me out a lot with setting up some things
in my business so I really shout out to
shout out to him I really appreciate it
and I've met Jake and Jake is a great
[ __ ] kid too and Logan I mean I [ __ ]
with both those dudes a lot and I mean
they're dogs so it's like I'm not I'm
not anywhere near that level to be able
to fight those promoters gonna do
something but if it was another dude
like who you know had who is this going
to be their first time fighting [ __ ]
yeah if we set it up and the money's
right let's do it the way those
promoters work you know because your
dad's Tom Hanks are like celebrity kids
yeah but see I'm not gonna fight Smith I
already I already got five both somebody
got somebody Jaden bring it
somebody [ __ ] real life you just go
crazy right Willow [ __ ] douche
somebody reached out you slap one of
them someone did reach out to me to
fight uh this one dude but it was just
like so uh it was like so d-list I was
like did I look like a [ __ ] idiot if
I fight this guy yeah it was the fake
Drake they asked me oh no no no no no
it'd have to be somebody who's like
popping you know what I'm saying Lopez
trains a lot what's up Mario what's up
AC Slater what's up Slater all right
that's no joke
all right second question is from Chris
Padilla uh hey dude huge fan from
Atlanta and lost my [ __ ] when you popped
up in Trini to the Bone yeah uh what's
that there was an episode of Atlanta I
did about uh Trinidad oh there you go uh
what was it like to be directed by
Donald Glover stay thick boys
Donald Glover is a g yeah genius right
genius yeah he's a [ __ ] genius really
nice guy he easy to get along with he
reached out to me like he had that role
basically written personally for me so
he hit me up and he was like would you
do this I'm like [ __ ] yeah let's do it
you know he's a guy who you're talking
about does many things you remember yeah
he does it all too
phenomenal he does it all too the
Atlanta award-winning you know director
I think that that song he did this
America was unbelievable yeah what were
you saying about gun control I owned
guns and [ __ ] but that [ __ ] was a that
was
um
ballsy amazing disturbing video and for
whatever he's so talented yeah he's very
special what else you got Jen all right
last question
uh this is from Dino Medina how is it
working with Larry David on Curb Your
Enthusiasm you or did you have a written
script or was it mostly improved and one
of my favorite episodes ever of curbs
what year was that uh I think that was
like 2017. one of the biggest shows of
all time like yeah it's a beast yeah
that was [ __ ] hilarious it's almost
all improv almost all of it actually got
a funny story about that so um Larry
David right I've actually known him like
since I was a little kid because our
parents were friends right so it's like
I I I I had known him like we we've gone
on like family vacations together but I
was I was a young kid you know what I'm
saying I was like probably like 12 13
years old so I hadn't really seen him
since then it's like I know him but I
don't really know him you know I mean as
an adult you know what I mean but I
auditioned for that role just like
everyone else and I and I [ __ ] got it
and I was right for the role so on the
first day of set on the or on one of the
days on set you know Larry David is
exactly
as you would expect him to be he's
literally he's the same guy he's the
exact same [ __ ] guy right himself so
so he's not not knowing that you know
like you know like he's not the type of
dude like that you're just gonna go up
to and be like hey Larry what's up like
then he's gonna be like he's gonna like
[ __ ] hate you well you're not gonna
get a part of you because that's what he
gets all day you know what I'm saying
like everybody comes up to him they feel
like they know him and they want their
moment of lariness you know what I'm
saying so like this is what he's getting
anywhere anywhere he [ __ ] goes so I
just it's Common Sense knew that that
I'm not gonna go and like trying to be
all buddy buddy with him so we're we're
shooting a scene in the car it was the
scene right before I pull up to the
valet and I hallucinated their red coats
and we're sitting we're we're sitting it
we're sitting in the car
and uh you know in between takes you
know we're we're just we're sitting
there so it's like the moment where you
know most people would try to make some
small talk yeah right because you're
just sitting there in silence in between
takes
well I didn't do that right I didn't do
that in between takes you know there's
that awkward silence and I know that he
was expecting this is the moment like
and like dreading like the moment where
someone's like so uh he's gotta be like
ah [ __ ] right but I didn't do that right
I just sat there like this like
just sat there I wasn't on my phone I I
was just sitting there but I wasn't
sitting there like awkward I wasn't
sitting there like
you're comfortable you know I was
literally just [ __ ] chilling dude
he's I'm sitting shotgun he's in the
driver's seat I'm just sitting there
like this right
and I could tell out of the corner of my
eye that there was that like silence I
could tell the corner of my eye he went
like this
and then actually he had the moment of
like should I say something like yeah
and then he was like and then he didn't
do anything he just went
huh you probably liked it he went like I
could I could literally see it out of
the corner of my he went huh yeah hell
yeah and then and then he was like so uh
Chet uh you know then we started talking
and shooting the [ __ ] and [ __ ] and he
had me [ __ ] cracking up sorry he had
me cracking up so hard like literally I
had tears coming down my eyes I was
trying to hold in this laughter right
before they said action I literally had
to [ __ ] compose myself yeah wow and
it was and it was hard and then and then
shortly thereafter we were both uh in
Sun Valley Idaho
because both of our families were there
and I needed to catch a flight back to
LA and he and he heard about it and he
was like oh I'm flying back to LA come
back on my private jet so we flew back
just me and Larry on his PJ and just
[ __ ] shot the [ __ ] how great no no we
talked the whole time
we were hella cool you know
yeah twice improper yeah um and and I
one thing I was playing in Italian I got
another thing I did a thing with him and
he was so [ __ ] great like because I
knew he's he is that guy he's very much
that guy but um like he he was he was
[ __ ] great we improvised then we
talked afterwards and he even said to me
he goes you're great you're just too
young for this role you know but but I
was so I was so impressed with how cool
he was because he was I I know Jeff
Garland really well so I worked with him
for a long time but um he's Then I then
I'm at a Premiere and he we're out in
the lobby and there's nobody else there
and he's looking at this thing and I'm
looking at this thing and you could see
he was the same thing just dreading just
don't say anything to me and of course I
didn't I didn't [ __ ] all two of them
yeah he's the creative genius he well
he's that's why I'm behind Seinfeld yeah
he's stand up you know he's just all
right Jim what do you got sure if it
breaks it's kind of like let's get away
you don't want glass in your head yeah
of course not but yeah it looked like he
was like hit him like this like you have
no really power like that he's like yeah
yeah
um wait I'm just curious Chet since you
mentioned uh you did have the cocaine
thing with the party I'm just curious
did your dick work when you're doing
musically or not okay that's what I was
curious no definitely good question
it's a good question because yeah no
that's why they say uh you know God
invented cocaine it's good for you but
your wiener doesn't work uh I use a
sense of humor I actually uh don't have
a problem in that regard if I do well
you know I haven't done I've done a lot
of Coke but the times I've done it I've
been rock hard chin okay good for you
dude I mean you gotta dive in with my
dick I'm not gonna be your dick is not
like nothing other people's dicks your
dick is like no my dick is all Americans
it's not real south it should have its
own TV show guys guys I might be skinny
but I got a dick on me all right so this
is the street parade after the Lionel
Messi and his team won the World Cup and
then pulls out of tits no so they're
going underneath this pass and it's you
see these wires look how close these
kids that's not good yeah so they could
have literally knocked off the bus
killed Lionel Messi yeah yeah we got to
be careful about that
all athletes all saw it coming yep
the one in the Hat then though he's like
whoa oh this is so close electrocuted
God nobody thought about that I heard a
great sportscaster described the
difference between Lionel Messi and
[ __ ] uh Ronaldo it was it was so
great because you guys who's the best
soccer player of all time right and this
you know Die Hard soccer man said if an
artist designed a soccer player he would
design Lionel Messi if an engineer
designed a soccer player he would design
Ronaldo you know Ronaldo's like just a
physical freak and you know tall and can
jump and Lionel Messi does [ __ ] the
people don't even like how did you make
that up how the [ __ ] did you do that
like what was that you know still that's
like maradon the same thing Maradona
what else you got chin uh just two more
so this was just I don't know what this
is exactly but this is in England and a
couple were walking their dog and it
looks like a ghost passed by them
watch
and apparently the park that they're
walking the dog in it's a coyote ghost
it's known for having a haunted woman
with a haunted coyote that looks not a
woman that is a a clear coyote that
looks like a sloth
is it I think it's very it's a tree
sloth no he's moving too fast it might
be a jellyfish
jellyfish it's a walking jellyfish we
call it a land jelly dude you know what
I'm that's the lamest thing oh I wonder
if they [ __ ] around with the camera I
can't stand [ __ ] like that we just found
this thing did you without a thing on
the camera that looked like [ __ ]
Dobby the elf from from uh Harry Potter
no dude see if you can this [ __ ] tell me
what you what you think this thing wait
before we go on do you believe in ghost
yeah I grew up in a haunted house carry
on you did yep why I didn't even know it
your dad's like it's for a roll no this
is this is some crazy so this is in July
I didn't even know that that it was
haunted until I was a full-grown adult
really they kept it from me oh my God
yeah look at this oh that's Brian Cowan
sleepwalking naked
and uh he did coaches
flip-flops it's Brian palette he only
wears [ __ ] flip-flops
what the [ __ ] is that that's a very
that's that guy it's that guy what the
[ __ ] is that guy's too scared I guess
too thick to be that guy that that was a
person who escaped some sort of there's
a video it might be a thermal image yeah
look at that dude
that is creepy I think that's being done
on purpose look how tiny it is yeah you
know what that is that's a professional
it's a very skinny it's a [ __ ] who's
leaving a house what the [ __ ] is that
that's a horde I've seen it on
Intervention that's what it is it's that
it's Gollum it's Brian Kelly it's
[ __ ] golf Ryan Kellen going to pee
outside at the night yeah it's me taking
my dog dude you know I'm gonna do it
there's no I believe in all that ghost
stuff when I'm in Vegas
no you don't yeah I do
no you know I believe in UFOs
conspiracies don't believe in all that
oh no I swear I do he had Zack Baggins
on and and like Zac Brown's like guys
he's a ghost guy and he's the Girl Scout
yeah dude and what he goes [ __ ] I
just got a tug of war with this ghost my
girl's bag it was pulling her bag and I
got into it and he I'm exhausted and I'm
going and I'm just I'm like he liar
that's when he's he's that's a great
dude but so on Ghost Adventures they
just went to I think I forget what
network now but the longest running
ghost show but in Vegas I'm there
January 5th through the 7th he has a
haunted Museum you know from like uh
what's that what's that movie that big
ass movie
um what's his freaking the The Conjuring
you know how that family which is true
story they would save all the possessed
stuff and put in their basement he was
like that but a museum
so I went on Ghost Adventures I was so
scared your face I was so scared you've
had so much plastic surgery thank you so
much you gotta stop getting work done on
your face look at how young you were
then I would love to go back on it was
so much fun I was so scared did you hear
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah and being like is it
real like it was real to me he's pretty
great Zach back and so because he'll
sell that [ __ ] he's good look at him
no that shit's real I grew up in a
haunted house really yeah I didn't even
know it was haunted do you know I knew
but I didn't I didn't I didn't have
proof until I was older what did you see
I I saw a [ __ ] ghost hey bro you're
being General I'm serious now but what
was the ghost okay so check this out so
check this out I grew up in this house
it was built in like 1920s it's not
Palisades yeah yeah
it was built in like 1920. well already
yeah always felt creeped out in the
house my whole life like any time like
every single day when the sun went down
it got nighttime I dreaded it because it
was just a creepy [ __ ] feeling in the
house at night time like a feeling of
being watched did everyone know that
feeling just you everyone felt it right
but I I would be vocal about it and
they'd be like oh you know you're
tripping because they didn't want to
scare me but come to find out like years
later I mean like literally a couple
years ago I'm a full-grown adult we're
talking about it one day or with my
family they're like oh yeah that house
is haunted we just didn't want to tell
you because that's like we didn't want
to freak you out but when they bought
the house when my mom bought the house
like literally when they were touring it
with the realtor and they're like okay
great we'll take it the realtor was like
okay great there's just one thing I need
to let you know the house is haunted but
nothing to worry the spirit is benign
and mom was like yeah whatever so she
got the house so they knew it off rip
this is season one America and there's
so much [ __ ] there's so much [ __ ] that
went down in that [ __ ] house dude
that would literally but I literally
thought I was insane because I never had
anyone to confirm all this [ __ ] I was
experiencing because they didn't want to
freak me out hey Dad I wish we could
move I wish they did
but but they didn't so I was literally
just always tripping because I thought I
was loosening I was losing my mind I'm
like am I tripping or you could see the
did that one time I saw it at the corner
of my eye
well I will say this it walks right over
I was it was a three in the morning yeah
it was three in the morning
I know I'm like up late on like a
Saturday night or something watching TV
my dog's chilling right there
watching TV there's there's Windows
overlooking the driveway on on this side
and literally I out of the corner of my
eye I see the silhouette of a [ __ ]
figure walk past the window and at that
exact moment my dog goes like literally
freaked out and I could literally I mean
I saw motion go by like a tough as a man
or woman I was just it was just the
silhouette of of a of a figure of a
person that literally walked right right
past the window I mean it was enough for
me to grab a [ __ ] baseball bat and I
went and walked around the house with
the dog to try to see if there was
somebody out there so here's my thing
with baseball bat what are you gonna do
hit through him I mean it's our first
sense go for a gun or baseball it's a
ghost it's a ghost but I didn't know
that I thought it was someone walking
around something our boy Court remember
Court who's a designer Interiors oh yeah
so I hired him to do my house he said
he'll find the kid Bill part of the kid
Jean back in the day he comes to my
house in Calabasas and he finds like
he's amazing because he'll go to Kansas
and find an old ladder from like the
1800s and put it on your wall it'll take
like he he'll like take old wood from
like some Railroad and put it on your
wall he's amazing so he likes the
necklaces out of slave teams no no no no
no not that but maybe but he uses all
these old [ __ ] that's not true but uh it
was George Washington's team and he's
right yeah yeah but um but he would uh
he'd have like some old chair and then
in our back room he has this giant
[ __ ] container it's like a a
container with a with a like a thing you
screw off I remember this is the
Calabasas house yeah the only portal is
this thing that you screw off and I
don't know the hell my wife immediately
goes I don't like that what is that and
he goes it comes it came off a haunted
ship and uh they don't know what they
used it for
hey Court hold please so he goes but
it's really cool so I go I like it and
it's too much to get it out we couldn't
how he got it in was like three dudes we
couldn't get it out so now it's in the
room it's the guest room
well what happened was my wife wouldn't
go in that [ __ ] room
then I come home a month later and she
goes you have to get that thing out of
there I go why she goes because I heard
a baby crying in there get the [ __ ] out
of here and I go you heard a baby crying
she goes yeah and it wasn't it was it
was moaning it wasn't crying so she
won't go up there
so and that's creepy as [ __ ] yeah so now
I go in the room and check it out
there's nothing in the room I turn the
lights on that's not how it works turn
the lights on and then I will say this
and I don't believe in ghosts I don't
believe in ghosts
I heard no about two weeks later
I heard it
and I have a weird thing about a ghost
in my [ __ ] house where my kids are
which I consider it a challenge you
don't like it I consider it a [ __ ] I
have a weird thing yeah we all do I
consider it a challenge get the [ __ ] out
of my house because my kids are here so
now you're on my territory so what I did
was I went all right
I'm going to keep the lights off
and I this is such a weird thing I was
you know you get that everything stands
up on your hair stands up I walk in
nobody's in the house
I [ __ ] open that midday no sir this
is at night okay I open the [ __ ]
thing
and in the dark I just stuck my head in
it's not how it works dude I just kept
my head in there you don't watch enough
and I closed my eyes and I was like I
dare you no I saw when they come out bro
I [ __ ] dared it
my eyebrows were plucked no but that's
true story and then uh we got rid of it
anyway and you still don't believe in
ghosts
um
I did all that you think you just have a
baby crying in your random room I don't
believe in ghosts or psychics only
because I've not had anybody tell show
me because I just haven't had enough
don't you believe in God I do believe
have you seen him
I felt him I've heard him and you felt
the ghost there's errors in your [ __ ]
philosophy my favorite is this my
favorite expression about God I think it
was a Eckhart uh [ __ ] Meister record
said yeah I've never I've never spoken
to God that I have heard him clearing
his throat in the other room
yeah do we believe that that steep [ __ ]
meaning um [ __ ] up I don't believe in
ghosts but I have heard a baby crying in
my guest room when there's no baby you
think there was a ghost
Ah that's creepy oh nothing worse I'd
rather have a grown man demon ghost than
a baby ghost yeah that's also baby
crying all night I told you that's where
my son told me I don't want my son was a
little boy because I don't want all the
uh stuffed animals on my bed same house
I go why because because they bite me at
night check please and I go and I go
watch this I go I don't see any I don't
see any marks on you they're just bit
his hands because he goes they don't
bite me on the outside of my body they
bite me on the inside oh my God now we
don't know if to be scared of the the
stuffed animals or your son that's true
then by the way I'm scared my wife came
in and and my son in like goes like this
she goes to put him to sleep and he
looks at her and he goes there's my
other Mommy and he goes your other mommy
where's the mommy you were what other
mama you were taught were you talking to
and he said
in the closet no again comes in she goes
you have to check Americans no American
Horror Story season two yeah that's the
exact same thing you know with uh my
little brother another story right is my
little brother when he was like four
years old
and this is my my dad is telling the
story at the dinner where it's revealed
to me that the house was haunted right
so all this [ __ ] is coming to the light
for the first time my dad tells a story
that when my little brother was like
four years old he walks by my little
brother's room he's like playing with
toys and talking like but talking and he
leaves him alone a few minutes later he
comes downstairs and uh my dad's like
hey bud uh what were you doing up in
your room and my little brother goes I
was just talking to the ghost
and my dad's like really show me so he
walks back upstairs he walks in his room
and my little brother walks around
looking at him oh it's gone now
that's not how it goes works and he had
never told us you know he had never told
that story until kids see [ __ ] when you
thought you were batshit crazy yeah it's
like no you know it caused you a lot of
pain and problems yeah yeah we all knew
yeah exactly you know the torture I've
been through yeah my mom the hours of
therapy dad I wasted [ __ ] money on
you my mom said she would talk to the
ghost she said she'd be in bed sometimes
and she'd feel the ghost come and sit
down on the edge of the bed sounds like
a nice ghost and she would say and she
would and I would just tell it to leave
I would just be like ghost please I need
to get some sleep can you leave me alone
and I'm like so you're having full-blown
conversations with the ghost and just
letting me think I'm [ __ ] insane you
you're batshit crazy yeah Jesus Christ
that engine you want one more you're
good give us one more win on one more
all right one more so this is
fascinating yeah 88 year old man from
France he somehow shoved a World War One
explosive is it artillery shell into his
butt and then went to the hospital later
on because I couldn't get it out why is
for sexual pleasure they found out later
my what a freak since it was an
artillery show they didn't know if it
was like you know effective yeah so they
had to evacuate the entire hospital and
then the guys in the bomb suit go into
his rectum like it's the movie Blown
Away just [ __ ] teeth
timer so it was eight inches long two
inches around well the thing is
how about you know the [ __ ] that it has
been no pun intended you know the [ __ ]
that has been in his [ __ ] a lot where
he was so bored he was like you know
what I bet that bombshell from World War
one I'm gonna sit on that bombshell and
then at what point he's like no man
there's no going back now I can't get it
out wow nothing's probably worth some
money too cash it's a collector's item
let me try a couple of Coke cans next
time it looks Rusty get a tetanus shot
[ __ ] face dude World War one yeah
well that's a good way to end uh yeah
man don't stick
in his spiritual journey and we're gonna
find the kid and it has a bomb thing
that went in somebody's ass but we did
confirm ghosts are real so that's cool
yeah both confirmed but you [ __ ] he
was talking about Coke and then you said
[ __ ] and that was not that's where it
went this the actors have managed with
Chad Hanks this is awesome yeah you got
that and then if they want to follow
your program and get on the nutrition
yeah thanks hanksfit.com
h-a-n-xfit.com Instagram you're always
plus down there yeah you can hit me up
on Instagram send me a DM now you did I
I saw you I think that was 225 he looked
like you were doing that
all right kids love you I will be uh
coming to Las Vegas first tour
announcement for 2023 Las Vegas Nevada
Wise Guys just got announced Thursday
show Almost sold out so Friday Saturday
two shows Friday two shows Saturday one
show Thursday
um I will be bringing my ghost from
Calabasas with me and I'll be at Zack
Baggins ghost Museum and my openers are
two ghosts as well that's Las Vegas
Nevada Wise Guys January 5th through the
7th Tampa January 20th through the 21st
Friday Saturday only another Springfield
Naples Bakersfield Oklahoma City we've
got a bunch of more tour dates coming up
so go to thickboy.com or fatkz.com but
Vegas Europe January 5th through the 7th
B all right guys Venice West this in in
Los Angeles in Venice December 27th uh
you guys should come down if you want to
laugh
uh it's two days after Christmas I don't
know the night uh Tuesday is it Tuesday
let me check my schedule check your
schedule I think I'm available all right
I love it laugh Boston come down laugh
Boston uh Boston Massachusetts December
29 30 31 San Diego California my drop
Comedy Club January 5 6 and 7. Fort
Wayne Indiana Summit comic club
briancount.com for all my dates and Chad
Hanks you're the man your inspiration
dude keep crushing excited you're
podcast gonna Crush man you can tell you
guys got to come on stories
yeah we'll definitely come on yeah I
don't want to go on right after your dad
but yeah yeah spread it out a little bit
and then we'll do that okay then I'm
down to come on for sure we love you
dude
we're out